boy I should have just posted the
podcast i did i tried to do this intro
like five minutes ago and it turned into
this mana [ __ ] festo that no one will
ever hear about hashtags and heartfelt
moments of my life um here's what's
going on this is an intro tour dates go
to barber com i am in philly Dayton and
Baltimore I think that's it maybe irvine
also in december tour dates are getting
canceled some in production i'm in
production to make money for my family
i'm not doing the podcast you love that
sometimes you're like how come you
haven't been a roegan to trust me if I'm
in town for two days I definitely just a
male Joe Joe schedule is packed so I
don't worry the second i can and our
schedules link up it will happen it's
same with Joey Diaz same with Ralphie
May all my friends I'm trying to get
them on my podcast I'm trying to get
them I'm treading on their podcasts but
I'm only home for two days possibly
sometimes and when I'm home I have to be
a dad and that is my number one priority
please respect this masculinity haha oh
yeah I'm obsessed with the hashtag
masculinity masculinity is so fragile
because mine is mine is horrible fragile
my masculinity is sitting on a ledge and
everyone's yelling jump including me um
I guess I have no masculinity I don't
even know if i'm masc at all I should
look up mask stop okay here we go great
block that's coming out today I'm
sitting in a hotel room in Michigan my
whole crews asleep my call is until two
out to do hours after theirs and and
I've having a nice cold that would have
been time better I'm having a nice cold
beer all right um
what I'm sorry to tell you oh I'm
thinking about doing this tell me if you
like this I was think I haven't read
that rolling stone article about myself
in 18 years I read it maybe twice tried
twice the day came out and that was it
and I realized that the other day a
friend I said friend of mine god damn it
let's [ __ ] semantics a guy I know on
Twitter Luca Luca Luca bana um posted
that he bought a copy of the
undergraduate my article in The Rolling
Stone magazine and I kind of it kind of
hit me weird and I thought I haven't
really I really thought about that
article in a long time I tried to
distance myself from it for a very long
time and I wouldn't say I was happen
till recently I started embracing it
maybe I got to [ __ ] nose my point is
I was thinking about reading it out loud
on a podcast reading the article from
beginning tanks I know that the majority
of me of you haven't read it and I know
that my audio book sold exponentially
better than my my written book because
I'm so good at reading aloud and I get
off track and I get and it's only six
nap pages so i think i can get through
that in easily an hour anyway uh so let
me know if you think i should do that or
not and if you want me to do what am I
saying i hears it can tell you this this
is the truth tell me if you think that
would be ego-driven don't say that
that'll be your driven just say like hey
Burt read the article would rather not
hear it on your mom cast be kind I have
a soft sole I have no masculinity all
right so that's it then I tell them I
stand-up dates for the barber com philly
baltimore dayton irvine not in that
order shooting both conquer if you hit
me up tell me where you are maybe we're
going to be in your town I know we're
going to ever go to Springfield we're
going to branson we're going to florida
we're going to utah we're going to
montana i think so hit me up let me know
all right today's guest today's guest
today's cast today's guest is from the
all things prominent comedy pat up
[ __ ] let me say that again
today's guest is a brother of mine on
the all things comedy network here's a
podcast called the long shot it's him
Jamie plan m amber Kenny his name is
Sean Conroy Sean and I have a past that
has inner mingled that's not the right
word John and I have yeah I have had a
few drinks he's a comic he's done UCB he
taught at UCB you'll hear all of this on
the podcast he's a fantastic performer
he's beaten me out for a couple rolls
and1 we'll talk about that I totally
forgot until he brings it up that and
the guy is massively funny massively
talented put your hands together do it
see what it feels like to clap by
yourself in your car and your cubicle
kafka for Sean Connery
yeah hey that's Mike right there you can
um it is oh it doesn't matter even if
it's on take the call um the calling of
the American mind it is I just heard it
on NPR and so I've never heard of the
term microaggressions ever heard
microaggressions no microaggressions is
a small guy wants to fight you that
probably actually is a micro resin
microaggressions are when um like you
say I was very guilty of it in the 90s
and well into the 2000s when you see
like an Asian person you go or a person
of mixed nationally go so what are you
and then I don't know I always found it
like I was probably it's like you don't
really have a right to ask that question
don't but then but but you're not being
hostile but in a sense it is aggressive
it is aggressive ya like like I'm sure I
was micro aggressive there's a woman we
know uh and she was adopted and then she
just found out she's like half black
mm-hmm and I was blown the [ __ ] away and
she was like an whatever and I was like
we need whatever like you just found out
your half but you're black you were like
come on man black lives matter like I'm
like if there's so much [ __ ] you need to
catch up on like right she was like well
doesn't change who I am and I go but but
if I found out that I was half black I
would totally change who I was like I
would dude I don't know it's like one
time I said in an audience member i said
uh oh my gosh somebody was
microaggression and he said Luke check
out Bert's album microaggressions he
said uh he said I'm part a part black
part Native American and I went oh how
cool and he went know what do you mean I
said I don't know man wouldnít awesome
to be Native American he goes no he's
like what are you I said just Irish and
German he goes so you think you'd be
more interested in yourself if you were
Native American right it rather be the
victims of slavery and genocide Yeah
right so um so anyway this calling in
the American mine is the whole thing
that Jerry Seinfeld was saying ah yeah
these did you have an opinion about well
I do think it's become an issue at this
point
I mean I I don't uh I probably haven't
thought about it enough to have a real
clear opinion on it right I do notice
certain things are hot buttons for
audiences and they get squeamish and
they go he said this thing and I don't
know how to react because it's funny but
I don't think I'm supposed to laugh at
that exactly um and I think that's not
good I think it's I think it's I think
it's sad and I think it's sad I mean
here's the deal is that I don't think I
don't think this time for ever really
did colleges like he doesn't write like
I don't think he really knows what he's
talking about him or Chris Rock I think
they're both it's like let them eat cake
they're like I'm gonna refuse to do
colleges from now on yeah I would love I
only have five billion dollars in the
bank I would love to see his quote
friend right right I would honest he's
liable to neca so but like I definitely
go I think I've definitely had that
profit colleges but I probably worked a
lot bluer than you should have at a
college mm-hmm you know and quite
honestly the kids that are going to
those shows are really like the coolest
kids right like I mean they were yeah I
went to all the comedy shows when I was
in college did you think yeah we well
know that's not true but I went to a
bunch of them I never knew we had to
come we had I mean we had like when I
was in college we had emo came to my
school a bunch of time using a pen yeah
I'm a massive beam of Judy Tenuta was
there kevin meaney was there remember
Kevin meaning [ __ ] funny because
kevin meaney was like I'm supposed to be
on saturday night live next year and
then I don't think he ever was or maybe
he was for like a season or something
but we're doing school I went to holy
cross college in Worcester Massachusetts
did you really where'd you grow up I
grew up in New York right outside New
York City yeah did you go into the city
as a kid I did actually with the high
school in the Bronx so really yeah I
went to high school in the Bronx mother
[ __ ] at a prep school is it is it
you're not you're not a agro dude but
was like from everything I know of you
you're not like a like a meathead frat
boy known about
I don't think so like but like there is
an interesting aspect of you is that
you're a big man so growing up there was
this challenge the big dog of course and
you're not that guy no but I got into
those things more than a few times like
what um I mean the worst one that ever
happened was this was after I got out of
college actually I was with two of my
buddies from college and they're both
little guys and we were in Larchmont New
York you know rough rough area right by
the yacht club and we were we were at a
bar and literally there's a place called
Larchmont yacht club not to be confused
too large much Shore Club which is a
very similar establishment but we were
at a bar and we had a few drinks and
then we're gonna go home and we decided
to stop off for one more at this place
that was called I still remember the
name of it cuz i wanted to firebomb it
for years after that it was called PK's
pub yeah and we walked in and we sat
down and immediately there was a table
of eight guys right next to us who were
like let's [ __ ] like we could hear
them going like let's kick the [ __ ] out
of these guys and one of the guys like
took his glasses off and put him in his
pocket and one of the guys turned to the
bouncer and said we're gonna fight these
guys is that cool and the bouncer goes
hey man this is all within our earshot
yeah the bouncer goes hey man haven't
gotten laid in two weeks I'm looking for
action let's do it and so one of the
guys start [ __ ] with one of my friends
who stands up and says you know just
leave me the [ __ ] alone and the guy
grabbed his shoulder so I jumped up and
grabbed that guy two of those guys
grabbed me so this is all within like
three seconds they swing me around hit
me in a smack my head into a support
stanchion split my head open so now I'm
like not unconscious but just stunned
and yeah you know pouring blood out of
my head and the bouncer grabs me from
behind I realized later was the bouncer
not one of the other guys it's a huge
plate glass window in the front of place
like in my head I'm going I'm gonna be
the guy from those movies who goes
flying through the plate-glass window
and it never works out like it does in
the movies oh you would be cut to shreds
if you if you did something like this I
just and then on your back I mean if you
just threw me on my back on the cement
I've even [ __ ] for a week but luckily
he did not he just threw me out on the
street because he didn't want any blood
on the floor in the bar and so then you
know I'm bleeding and ambulance comes
they take me to the hospital like it
else I got like 13 stitches in my head
where do I can't even see the scar no
it's on the top undermined I don't think
it's that big anymore this was a long
this was in 1947 so this is a long time
ago um but but so then we go back
there's there's literally a police
station right across the street from the
bar so we go back to this police station
it's five in the morning they've taken
witness statements from everybody at the
bar yeah and I go into the police
station [ __ ] head bandaged I look
like the little drummer boy from the
revolution and I'm like I want to yeah
I'm like I want to press charges against
these guys in the cops like well they
said that you guys were harassing the
girls they were with all night so and
the girls agreed with them so you guys
are you know it's their word against
yours and you're gonna and it was like
we were literally walked in and got in a
fight like how could we have harassed
not that I'm above you know I love
harassing the [ __ ] out of girls that I
don't know yeah it's one of my favorite
type of my thing dude cat calling ya
can't believe that became a thing what
are you doing with those suits baby to
get a real man that's exactly what
[ __ ] human being questions the choice
of a woman right in front of the man
like what [ __ ] oh my god so it was
very frustrating and that's why I say
four years after that I was like because
everybody just lied and that's you know
that was when I really sort of realized
that's what you do in a bar fight is you
just lie about what happened and it
becomes well he said this but you said
this and then there's no way to get to
the truth you know that's [ __ ]
infuriate well I guess now probably
places would have liked Cameras Cameras
and now things
change drastically like and I I probably
for the good probably i don't know i
don't know I've always lived my life a
little bit like someone's watching me
mm-hmm when I was in college I got
written up as the number one party
animal country and I said a bunch of
things to a magazine magazine and I was
number eight hundred and sixty-four well
it's still top thousand yeah yeah I was
up there yeah um that's a blue chips I
was a chip recruit I was in the majors
you know and I said something to some
magazine and ever since and then they
used it and it was very it was like very
telling I was like whatever I told the
guy go this is off the record and nice
that didn't work and so cut to I
remember being humiliated and feeling
horrible and my dad said you know you're
not that'll never happen your life ever
again now that this once cuz you need to
be cognizant of how you are representing
yourself all the time and even like I'm
sure if told the story before but I got
if you ever done acne or not acne um
house of comedy in the mall of america
no in Minnesota ya know there's a
[ __ ] there's a hotel attached to the
mall and you got to walk through the
mall but sometimes the hotel door closes
and you gotta walk out of them all in
and around through the garage into the
ferry front door of the hotel which is a
pain in the ass haha so I go to the
doors closed and I hit the button and
the guy says can I help you I said yeah
I can open the doors and he gives me a
handicap I was like no like think and
like define handicapped yeah and he goes
why can't open it if you're not
handicapped and then I go oh ok yeah I'm
with a guy in a wheelchair by the way
I'm with nobody uh-huh and he goes no
you're not i said no i really am i with
a guy in a wheelchair a blind guy and he
goes I don't believe you I said being
that serious and I go to talk to him so
then I like get lower to the call button
and I'm like American you'll understand
and i'm doing characters I can't see you
but I'd appreciate if you let me in I
had so he goes I'm not doing it man i
don't believe you and so then I walk
around to the [ __ ] front I walk out of
the ball to the front of things I walk
in and it's the guy behind a desk and he
goes are you are you the guy
the blind guy in the wheelchair and I
said to him I go yeah where are they
because I guess I you say the mall man
and I put it on him I was like not cool
man another in the mall and there's a
guy in a wheelchair on a blind guy that
or just [ __ ] me entering in the mall
I was like dude I don't Sam heard by the
way I go to my room the last day like
I'm checking out on Monday morning and
it's him again all the other guys are
laughing behind the thing I think I
guess you know we have video like we can
watch you doing that like week and I was
like what he's like yeah we've been
watching you do your characters and I
was like [ __ ] and in my head I
was like don't let that video go out cuz
what like but then that's the only thing
that sucks about this viral video it's
like yeah I'm sure be probably nothing
but good for my comedian does characters
outside door of and then in my head I'm
like let's get in front of this I'm
start talking about this on stage but I
don't know what did you win did you when
did you start to expand up I started
doing stand-up in 98 did you start doing
stand-up or improper improv I had been
doing improv since 47 no I started doing
improv in 1989 actually in college no
after college it was like right after I
graduated from college I graduated in 88
in New York I started in New York at UCB
know it was this was long before you see
became to town I actually started with a
group called falling rock zone which was
out of Yonkers New York really um yeah I
had no I was like I'm gonna be a
comedian but I had no idea how to do it
or what that entailed you know so for
like four years i worked with this short
form improv group and we would perform
maybe once a month you know and that's
not the way to sharpen your instrument
um so finally finally I just start I
decided to start my own thing so I like
booked a theater in the city and I gotta
actually put an ad in backstage and got
a bunch of people to perform with me and
did a thing that ran for two months and
out of that I was hired into a group
called Chicago City Limits which was an
off-broadway show in New York and I got
into their national touring company I
spent the next four years touring the
country with them and then it was like
right at the end of that time so like 96
when you see be came to town and I
started studying with them and then in
98 I started doing stand-up on my own I
was the reason I started doing stand-up
really was because I got to the point
where I was like I'm really I'm really
good at improv but when people come to
see improv shows it's very hard to go I
mean it's not impossible but you don't
always go like oh that one guy was
really great everybody else was lucky to
be on stage with him were part of your
job as an improv everybody else look
good yeah make everyone look good yeah
which not everybody is good at but you
know I like to think I am good at that
that's why I was never good at improv
yeah i know i mean stand-ups have a
really hard time you know really hard
time with improv because I literally I
want to be the funniest person so I got
to that point where I was like I got to
do this so I can just be on stage where
myself and I'll take all the credit and
all the blame and yeah so I so I did
that sweet when you first did stand-up
we were just like I'll just wing it no
no no I took a class actually really
yeah we're um the guy's name god I don't
remember his name Steve something or
other in the city yeah and it was you
know I always tell people don't take a
class as a stand up its not worth it
take you know improv classes and sketch
classes are great that was the big
debate that I'm sure you were abreast of
when the Kyle cease thing remember that
yes and and and was it Matt Besser yes
it was you're right i forgot about that
you know you're buddies with besserer i
am yeah and Besser was like was like and
Kyle seems like it's the same as improv
it's not the same as if it's not at all
the same i believe that i believe i
think i agree with you stand up classes
i believe are pointless yeah if it's the
way that you need to get into stand-up
that's what it was for me well that's
why going into a classroom it was like
an open mic except you were paying more
money than you would an open mic yeah
and what it got me was I think the class
was like two weeks long or three weeks
twice a week for three weeks so I did
six open mics basically I came up out of
it going I am 50 times better than any
of the people that are doing this yeah
so I should go off and start doing real
Mike's and doing you know trying to get
booked shows and blah blah blah so it
was what I needed because I you know one
of the reasons i stayed doing improv for
so long i think you know is is the fear
of being alone on stage and being the
only one it's kind of possible i would
love to be good i mean i'm good at
improv but i'm bad at being in an improv
group troop like I'm bad at the mm-hmm
I'm I'm like a I'm a scene stealer and
I'm a lot line stealer uh-huh like if
the lines out there I won't I'll run in
grab I would have a lot of micro
aggression against you if you were at my
important I would be very I'd be
interested to take it in probably what
were you thinking when you did that
thing maybe I should this December I'm
staying all December in LA Oh a month
i'm not working at all maybe I should
take like an improv class I think I'm
gonna enjoy it yeah it'd be fun good
talking about because I like not fun for
your classmates but oh I i like i like
improving on stage lot bald and probably
on stage but to me that's you talk about
when you're doing stand-up i love not
having anything no that's a totally
different muscling people always go like
we've taken so much improv you must be
able to use that in your stand-up all
the time and i always feel like it's
like saying will you you know you've
played so much basketball that must
really help you with your baseball like
it's two totally different things to
really yeah so it's define the muscles
if you can um improvising with other
people is like really listening to what
they're saying and reacting to it and
making it make sense whereas i feel like
when you're improvising as a stand I
mean I guess part of it is when you're
doing crowd work really listening to
people in reacting to ya and and trying
to come up with stuff so in that sense
there is a similarity but I just feel
like it's you know to me it's more when
you're doing stand-up coming up with
funny things on the spot out of you know
off the top of your head which is just a
different skill as far as I'm concerned
it's um ya know it could this is gonna
sound silly but like could you take an
improv class and learn anything from it
right now could I yeah probably I
probably could
he's taking an improv class like taking
tennis lessons uh like your own it's
you're still practicing so you're just
getting better I think yeah I think it
would just make you go back to check
your your fundamentals and go am I
really practicing what I have been
preaching for 20 years you know because
I always felt I haven't taught improv in
a couple years but I always felt when I
was teaching improv it was really
helping me with my improv because i was
like thinking about it a lot and
explaining why i felt the way I felt
about what people were doing yeah and
then I would apply that it stay the same
I stand up when you're on the road
you're working with a feature and you
can see his lazy habits and you pulled
my side you go hey listen just giving
you a heads up like the stuff you're
doing is it does it is killing you're
not getting stronger from it right and
then you start going mmm here when
you're talking with that are you talking
about a feature that you're bringing
with you or somebody that's there
someone that's there yeah someone that's
there or someone that someone that I
brought people with me that I've given
advice this guy Aaron clobber who is
very funny but like and he was
destroying and I told him I said you
getting into a lot about habits like
you're it because there is this there's
this mindset as a feature on the road is
if I kill hard enough I'll get to be
albe they'll make me a headliner next
year mm-hmm and that's never happens
right there's so many things that go
into being ad liner right that have
nothing to do with being [ __ ] funny
that so little of it so many clubs yeah
I've never even seen the headliner
that's coming to their club do stand-up
right and and I just was like you're
going about the wrong way the right the
right way to do it if you want to go
about being a good feature find a guy
you can work with who um you like his
stand-up and you do your thing but then
help him with his stand up to right like
like like meh Voltron and I travel a lot
and he'll like sometimes like if I'm in
private on stage he'll just sit in the
back and have a beer and listen to me
selling it means can't go anywhere
anyway like what's gonna do go for a
walk and so just listen to me and if I
say something new or something funny in
a way I haven't done it he'll like pull
me inside and write it down right and
just be like hey screaming your heads up
you said that differently and then you
go wow you're valuable to me in a weird
way like as opposed to going
I'm just [ __ ] destroying and being
like okay great now I gotta I mean I I
haven't I haven't done a lot of road
work and I certainly haven't done a lot
of road work as a headliner like I would
say only maybe one or two or three times
but i did for four or five months tour
as a feature with mike birbiglia and
that was exactly what it was is that I
would just sit and watch him and then we
would talk about asset afterwards and he
and he would give me stuff on my set to
what was also funny was when we did that
we would show up somewhere you know
until we'd be there like Wednesday to
Sunday right so first show Wednesday
night local a MC would go up and after
that show Mike would say look he'd go to
the club and say look let's just have
Sean do half an hour and then I'll do my
thing because all those guys were just
the worst it was it is it's really it
you know that's low low lowest common
denominator comedy across the boards
it's what they what it is is they want
they want to do well in front of good or
well they want to do well they want to
do well in front of her big Leon you so
they want to destroy but they're doing
like eating [ __ ] and like you know and
it's just like that doesn't fit I mean
that doesn't hesitate at the knife what
Mike is doing yeah you know not that I'm
sure Mike doesn't occasionally enjoy
[ __ ] snacks you know he just keeps it
on the dl I don't [ __ ] it isn't he
doesn't make a show about that but yeah
it's it's one of those things we just go
like oh man if you had just paid a
little bit of attention you could have
you could have had a great week just go
up into a tight five tight 10 that's
smart do the stuff that you're working
right because what it does is it [ __ ]
up the whole show in a sense by setting
that as the bar at the top of the show
yeah i think you know maybe that's what
[ __ ] comedy classes should be is it
only for working comics mm-hmm you okay
come in you get you all you got to do is
buy a beer or something for the comic
and you just get like a headliner come
in and like like David tell SAT me aside
I'm certain I probably told us but I'll
tell it again it's like right we haven't
told it to me but I I know by feel I
always get self-conscious uh-huh I right
when we had Georgia I got a I got an
offer we were I was broke had no money I
said I had this conversation with LeAnn
yesterday I had no money and I had Aaron
from the improv offered to fly me to UM
to uh miami-fort Lauderdale and back to
Miami for three weeks in a row and I
would make 700 bucks a week and my agent
was waving his percentage and my manager
was waving his percentage so that I
could get like some money cuz I just had
a kid right and the weeks were Lucy k
Dave Attell and Daniel Tosh featuring
each time I was featuring for all them
and I worked at the town I'm patel's
been the [ __ ] top of the mountain for
me my entire career he's amazing he's
the best comic alive in my opinion and
all I wanted him to do was say you're
funny that's it no you know it's a very
big deal and some guys are very like
stingy about saying that you know
there's a lot of guys won't tell you
you're funny yeah there's and and maybe
it maybe let me rephrase that maybe I'm
not funny and a lot of guys haven't said
it to me but there are guys I just go s
interesting I say it's a [ __ ]
everybody I'd like no III it's funny I
was thinking about that because i have a
very specific memory of you you and I
don't if you remember this you and I
auditioned for something together years
ago at vh1 and I eventually booked it
and then was immediately fired after
they started shooting it and then I
didn't see you for like ever seen
monsters yes yes I didn't seem for like
two years and I ran into a Starbucks out
here and you were like dude I got to
tell you you were so [ __ ] funny in
that a dish dammit you were which I
which I was like that was so [ __ ]
cool what you were and I and I was and
by the way the other person that got it
was um Daphne Daphne Brogdon uh-huh and
they replaced you with matt price nice
Matt price mm-hmm and and that I
remember doing that audition and going
oh I wouldn't be I'm not the but what's
funny is looking back at it when I was
fired or right before I was fired
because we shot like a test episode yeah
I know exactly why it didn't work out
because when I was doing the audition
with you I was just loose and [ __ ]
around in the room when I got on the
show I was writing all these jokes but
then there were other writers on the
show who were my friends who were also
writing jokes so I was trying to get
everybody's jokes in including my own
which was like no serve yourself in that
situation don't worry about what a
writer what would have been good for you
I end up doing two episodes of it oh you
did yeah oh I don't know what the [ __ ] I
was talking about who gives a [ __ ] yeah
what's what what's fascinating about
this is I had done um I could not do
what you were doing in that room because
I couldn't think that quick right and I
didn't understand how you were thinking
that quick well but what's funny is when
they were before they fired me this
executive came to my dressing room
before the second episode which was
really the first episode the first real
episode that we were going to shoot and
he goes he goes Sean and see he vh1
didn't hire me i was hired by the
production company so vh1 was just
getting to know who I was yes and he was
like Sean look we need you to be like a
fun guy who's having fun at a party and
I was like Fred his name was Fred I said
Fred I'm not a fun guy having fun at a
party even when I'm a fun guy having fun
at a party and he was like we'll just do
what you can't so thinking back on that
I'm like that would have been perfect
for you oh yeah well I ended up those
were the two funniest things I've ever
done on television really ever and they
were really good for my not getting the
job was tough on me cuz I thought I
thought I'm perfect for this and then I
went into the room he would have been
pregnant before and but you were so much
you were visibly funnier than everyone
oh I remember that and I went and I
remember walking out going I [ __ ] that
up and then I and always like I was like
I didn't [ __ ] it up I just couldn't hang
like I didn't know how to hang and I
remember thinking about that and they
were like you did it they call me back
you did a great job it's just you not
the right guy for the show we need a guy
who's an improv guy who can bounce off
other people
okay and so and I done TV enough TV
before that I was comfortable doing TV
and they said we'd love to have you back
to do one episode great and cuz i knew i
knew Marin and uh and so and I knew dat
and I new Daphne I'd worked with Daphne
Daphne and worked on another show with
me before that and so I show up to thing
and marin pulled me in his dressing room
he's like give me everything you got on
Daphne you got to tell me everything and
I was like I was like why he's like
driving me up the [ __ ] wall and I was
like really then I knew price because I
knew I'd know jason nash so I talked to
price and then I'd go down it is that it
is by the way I go down and I didn't see
when I went wait what happened and
they're like he got fired i talked to
kurt metzger about it I go he goes he
got fired I go why he was like I have no
[ __ ] idea like it and so but I I know
why also what's funny is years later
Marin was like like literally within the
last couple years Marin was like just so
you know I had nothing against you I had
nothing to do with you being fired and
so immediately now I'm gonna torture him
every time I see him and go you got me
fired didn't you he he so I go on and it
was it was interesting there were so
many notes given to price and Daphne
there were so much heavy lifting given
to them that they were having a very
hard time being funny because they were
trying to remember everything to do
right and I didn't have to do anything
and I remember thinking his [ __ ] around
and I thought that's how you handled the
audition right is it you just smiled and
I went and I went oh you know what the
better of this job is being the guy that
gets to [ __ ] around and in that thing
they did so one of the things they did
was um I what I'm gonna get the guys
name exactly mm-hmm because they would
it's called ember minds Buzzcocks it was
a butt game show but was like celebrity
game show so was it kind of weird like
weird shows weird shoaib it was very
successful this in in the UK and so they
bring out a celebrity that no one has
seen in a very long time right the guy
for us was the lead singer of lover boy
so no idea so they put four guys I'm
gonna find lover boy I'm gonna find Mike
Reno was his name of course I was they
said good old Mike they said you got to
figure out which one's lover boy and
they're all standing there for guys one
of them is my green 03 or not we don't
know what my green looks like anymore
right and they're all standing there and
they're like Daphne's team you guys get
to go first and they're like um and
there's what they're doing is they're
assessing him they're like my well you
figure lover boy was in they were big in
86 how old are these got what are these
guys this guy looks to load this guy
looks too young well you figured he
partied a lot so look at their eyes look
at the right none of it's fun so they
really were like fun people having fun
at the party yeah it was not it was it
was before it was not none of it's funny
and and the guys are all kind of looking
off at the audience as if they're in a
lineup and they can't make eye contact
right right I go guys we're going about
this the wrong way and they're like
really go yeah watch this I go hey Mike
and one guy turned his haha I it got the
biggest fun and laugh and I and I and
and I [ __ ] made it to the next I'd
like and I picked Mike and I go that's
my green oh we win so the executives
come up to me and they're like hey can
you stay one more day she'd another and
I was like I felt so redeemed the fact
that I was like okay I figured out how
to be funny on TV don't be more like you
were like the Nazis at the end of the
Great Escape what was that do you ever
see that movie with Steve McQueen No ok
it's a great movie it's the movie where
he's locked up in the cooler with the
ball bouncing the ball against the wall
it's the one where he jumps the
barbed-wire fence on a motorcycle yeah
but all these English guys escape from a
German POWs camp and they're getting
away they're getting why they all split
up they're going to different parts of
Nazi Germany they're getting away and
two guys are on a bus they both speak
fluent German and they the Nazis come on
the bus and they're like speaking to
them in German you know let's see your
passport documents and they have fake
documents they give in to him whatever
the Nazis are satisfied they start to
walk away and then one of the Nazis
turns back and says in English and goes
have a nice trip or something like that
and the guy goes thank you and they're
like we got you Oh [ __ ] yeah
that's exactly what I did oh yeah that
was
that was that that was the what cuz I
just gotten the I've been on a show
they're going canceled I then had a
pilot that didn't get picked up and then
I had I had bombed on an honor on a
showcase and I and I went out for this
was like the next thing and I didn't get
it and I and I was and I was visibly bad
and things I learned from that was don't
I like in my egos bruised because I
remember I in the room I remember in the
room doing this I remember I remember
vis I few started crying I remember that
I I remember looking at you with my
mouth up and going how the [ __ ] is doing
this like you're so naturally you're so
confident and I was like and I was
auditioning I wasn't having fun I was ah
right right that's the key yeah like if
you're auditioning you're [ __ ] if
you're just doing it and that's
literally that's the only that audition
was the only time I've ever felt like
that in an addition ever you murdered it
and I and I remember thinking I'm not
running into you in thinking this whole
time I failed know what no no that kind
of just [ __ ] killed I need to
celebrate how [ __ ] good he is and
take a look at it and go how do I apply
it to my life I know I haven't until
recently I mean dead serious ever apply
that in my life I was a guy that would
going to an audition and I would I was
really bad at if I could go back and
struck this career all over again and I
give an advice to a guy coming in do it
your way from day one right [ __ ]
whatever you don't fare don't think
whatever the [ __ ] the casting director
is looking for error because if you do
with the casting directors looking for
you'll be doing that for [ __ ] five
years right you've been doing an
impression of what the casting directors
would have liked I and I I really [ __ ]
up a lot well what was great about me
getting that job was that it was like
that was my first thing that I really
booked so it was my big break my career
was really on the way then you know and
I was teaching at UCB and I had to go to
all my classes and say I'm really sorry
you guys but I've gotten my big break so
I'm gonna be taking off I'm in show
business now o meanie I'm mama no you
know and then immediately fired and was
like can I come back and teach the rest
of those classes I didn't fire you oh
that's actually a funny story in and of
itself first of all we taped that
episode and I come offstage and nobody's
around like the hallways are empty in
the studio and what I found out later
was that Sebastian Bach
was getting everybody high but they're
already must have been something in the
air like you know how there's like the
one guy and everybody's like I don't
know if this guy's gonna I don't know
and it so that you don't to be around
that guy he's like the Jonah on the ship
you know yes I must have already been
the Jonah on the ship so I come off
stage there's nobody around I just was
like okay I guess I'll go home so I went
home that was on Saturday Sunday morning
my manager at that time was Carrie
Hoffman the owner of stand-up New York
Oh max mix him up with Jeff singer well
very very different temperaments but
Carrie of course better known for his
Frank Sinatra impersonation than for his
managing skills so so I have this
experience on Saturday it feels really
weird to me if it feels weird it is
weird and they've already said like we
need some of this from you we need you
to do more this so i know there's
something up so carry on sunday morning
i'm not home calls and leaves me a
message and his message is this you know
and carries like as he himself says he's
like I'm an old Jew from Queens so he
sounds kind of like Jackie what's that
guy's Jackie Mason Jackie Mason yeah
he's like section it's cari Huffman I
have terrible news for you terrible
terrible news but I don't want to leave
it on your machine so please call me
back as soon as possible so I do I knew
immediately like oh you wouldn't would
you like please see if your pc is cancer
please say as cancer is it me or you
like what is he gonna think that I'm
gonna think it is like I found out your
mother's dying you know a bearable
terrible terrible news but I don't want
to leave it on your machine it was so
great oh oh my god you calling he just
said yeah you fire yeah that was it I
have [ __ ] sucks yeah dad they died i
did an episode with sebastian bach i
love getting high with sebastian bach of
course i ended up getting uh Tiffany was
on that episode and so is Joey McIntyre
amber thiessen no Tiffany Oh tiffin just
tiffany tiffany enjoyment i let the
music player or what was her music pass
at her I don't know get away um and
sharad small me sherratt sharat small me
joey mcintyre sebastian bach and tiffany
& Molly cleaver Molly Culver she might
have been on the one before I don't like
hanging around mala Culver she was on
Pam Anderson's spy VIP VIP uh-huh and
she and Mike over is still friends with
Daphne Brogdon to this day oh really
which means you're still friends with
Stephanie if you know that Daphne
Brogdon has a show on cooking on cooking
called Daphne's dishes and I used to
hook up with Daphne oh there's my hooked
up with daphne was definitely was my
definite was my experience of don't [ __ ]
where you eat we were on a TV show
together we hosted it together and we
live I mean like literally while the
show while you were doing the show you
hooked up whoa first week yeah that's a
good idea so we started hooking up right
away and like spend the night at each
other's houses and and it was like an
litter and then and then we started I
started hooking up with someone out like
I we started not hooking up and then we
but we still it was very big show was
weird it was very weird and then
everyone wanted to play this sexual
tension and and it didn't work well and
any but I was still and that's gonna be
movie with Will Ferrell in it coming
soon yeah it's so but I don't know how
we got on anyway so you were gonna tell
me about what a tell said to you at L
took you aside and sad it's not it's a
boring story no no I want to hear it
because I actually like to hear those
kind of thing at L said to me at the
thing at the first walk in we did two
shows Thursday to chose Friday to show
saturday to show sunday he's selling out
like crazy it's the height I'm sure
there's been higher points but this is
during it is on the massive way up
during at omni ack insomniac right and
so and i just been on Last Comic
Standing uh to I just been profiled and
so I and that was when like 13 million
people watch that so I go out back when
TV was TV [ __ ] and so I go out I went
with her that works just gonna go hey
guys we lost it I think they've already
done that too
certain extent like why are you can't
let me think yeah just put it all up
there like the internet doing TV we got
four people last night so doing well
it's better than mine yeah we started
leaving a comment section you should I
you should hear the way I've
deconstructed making TV felt like just
make it the lowest common denominator so
that [ __ ] just stick around just
watch please just watch I swear to god
I'll eat a goat stick like um then so
this fall on NBC Dave Attell says I go
out the first show I come out people
know who I am so i'm i'm already
murdering like right and i'm doing a lot
of the jokes that i'd done on the show
which is a big deal like and so I do
like 15 destructive get off stage like
how are they I said they're great he's
like okay I was like you're gonna
[ __ ] do great so he goes on a key
murders comes off done tanning second
shadow i go on i do even tighter faster
harder i can often he goes I go he goes
how are they I said they're great he's
gonna [ __ ] kill go out he didn't even
hang out don't speak to me just leaves
goes to his hotel room next next day
coming I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ]
destroy he's gonna he's gonna have to
say he's gonna have to hear the laughter
and say you're funny so he kind of come
out I tried to it literally that 15
minutes I do it like [ __ ] 1450 not I
mean it's so perfect come off and he's
like okay why is it terrible like
destroying and he goes all right we get
it you're funny about you tell a new
joke and I'm like what isn't been
watching all your [ __ ] shows and it
took the same [ __ ] is that what you're
gonna do and I was like no he's like do
you have more material is that it is
that all you've got like real like I was
like no I've got a lock regression he's
like why wouldn't you why wouldn't you
tell the other jokes too he's like are
you just are you scared and I was like
no he's like can you write and I was
like yeah he's like and then he goes on
stage destroys and I go watch him and I
realized he hasn't been doing the same
act every time at all let alone has he
been doing the same joke the same way
he's finagling jokes in his reworking
jokes and he's putting different tags
are the different ends and he's working
his set I get off and he's like can I
give you some advice and I was like
please he's like you're funny but if
you're just gonna do the same act over
again I'm not gonna watch you because if
you'd like to write and work on your
craft
I'll watch you and then you know we can
talk about it and I was like that's all
I want that's all I [ __ ] want is you
just accept me and tell me some of the
ideas about what I'm doing wrong and
he's like it's like you're never gonna
get this opportunity again to travel
around and and no one gives a [ __ ] how
you do right I said when he goes no one
care feature he's like no one's watching
you and you're not gonna lose the job as
long as I say you stay you stay I'm not
going anywhere so how about you right
and I was like yeah and so I literally
looked at featuring that day one harms
indifferent and all I would do is write
featuring and it was like a feature for
a full year after that at the end of the
year I started headlining and and you
were ready and I was and when I started
headlining I was like I'm probably
wouldn't totally ready but like I would
at the end of the year I was like oh my
god and now i learn how to write on
stage now I know how to and I was like
the best advice ever given to me and I
was like and the but it's amazing like
David Hill would say one joke that he
liked and I would as soon as he said
that I was like I'll be saying that
every [ __ ] show for the rest of my
[ __ ] life right it was a joke I just
watched beach street and when I was a
kid I watched beat street and so I
thought that's what I'll do is I'll tag
I'm gonna take part of that movie and
incorporated into my gated community so
I got a can of spray paint and then
right where it said Faircloth estates I
just checkin up on and I'm out riding my
name and then I go [ __ ] I'm the only
Burton this deeper and so I wrote under
it sucks dick and it tells like that's a
great joke I was like oh really and I
told it every [ __ ] time I got a stage
I don't know yeah but I feel like that's
I mean you know that's something I've
never I've never really done I did that
like i said i was with biglia for four
or five months and i did that to a
certain extent during that time but to
have that opportunity that's where you
really grow as a comic and you know I
mostly do shitty bar shows around La and
it's really hard in a seven minute set
and I also you know my own ego gets in
the way because I'm like I can't not do
well in front of these people when
really what your attitude should be is
like who cares who came not getting paid
they're not paying to see the show who
cares you always have that in your head
you have that lottery ticket feeling of
like what if
what if will ferrell's there right and
he just comes up he's like you know I
got a movie you're [ __ ] hilarious it
that's the thing that [ __ ] sucks
about LA yeah is that there is this like
I go up one night and I'm like I'm like
I don't I'm it's a sold-out show and I'm
like I do not give a [ __ ] it's at the
improv and I'm like I'm gonna [ __ ]
around and im gonna do all new jokes and
that's what this hearts about and I'm
literally like good so i got my notebook
out and i'm like flipping through it and
[ __ ] steve byrne walks up behind me
he's like do your a [ __ ] i was like what
he's like Vince Vaughn's in the audience
I'm like haha but one guy you want to
impress like for me I really think his
well and you always want to impress
Steve Byrne yeah I would steved seaburn
took me on the road a couple times when
I was first starting out he was very
nice to me really yeah Steve's very
different types of act very yeah Steve's
a really sweet guy and he really does he
really does like like what he wants
people to [ __ ] he like wants to share
the road with people right I'm like that
sometimes but my gerd me though because
he would be driving and then he'd also
be looking through his giant volume of
CDs at the same time trying to decide
what music to put on I'd be like Steve
eyes on the road please I don't wanna
drop a micrograph would you want to do
more road work um I I'm at the point now
I mean yes absolutely and in fact I have
sort of this fantasy that I'm going to
go on the road for like two or three
months at some point in the next year or
two the problem is now I've started
writing for TV yeah you want to know a
small uh for mr. pickles yeah yeah um I
am hopefully working with a guy who ants
did some animation from oh cool girls
we're doing an animated series for
Comedy Central oh it's not serious let
me rephrase that we're doing some [ __ ]
right and so but I so I saw that now I'd
like in part of Israel's with mr.
pickles episode and that's [ __ ]
laughing which episode you remember ah
it's not even episode I'm sure it's just
a sizzle clip it's a clip it's a mr.
pickles any [ __ ] killed the bigger
one is the craziest it's like taking
drugs watching that tell everyone what
it is mr. pickles is a show for adult
swim it's an 11 and a half minutes show
but we like to say that it's really a
22-minute show crammed into 11 and a
half minute
because it moves quickly it's so [ __ ]
fast um but it's basically it's it's
basically lassie I mean mr. pickle's is
like lassie he's just a dog who lives
with an all-american family but what the
family doesn't know is that mr. pickle's
worship Satan and is a serial killer so
he's always off up to some sort of
mischief of murdering people and the
grandfather of the family knows that mr.
pickle's does all this stuff but
everybody just thinks the grandpa is
just a senile crazy person so they don't
listen to him I love the way that I love
the way the show is I guess edited is
but it it's very that's one thing I said
to him when I first talked to the guy I
was like I was like dude I loved the
transitions like a move so quickly yeah
it it's seamless and it it's seamless in
like in like a perfect way really will
car soul is one of the two creators and
he does all the the direction in the
editing him see you do you do a voice on
there too I do a bunch of voices yeah I
was the head writer and what's great
about that aside from aside from being
the [ __ ] head writer of a TV show is
also that when we are working on scripts
in the room you know the script is up on
the on the monitor and I'm like okay
let's read through the scene and so I'll
read through the scene out loud doing
all the voices myself like not casting
it or anything yeah so then if those
guys the two guys who created the show
hear a voice that I'm doing that they
like then they go okay well as have you
do that in the show so I've gotten to do
a bunch of voices in the show which is
awesome great I was one I always think
working for adult swim I used to have a
friend who was a guy that we party with
a couple times he lived in Atlanta Adult
Swim's out of Atlanta right yeah lived
in Atlanta I forget his name TNT you
know Turner Broadcasting happening so
and he was I've we went and what we went
me him and this guy chris killen went
watched um Tim and Eric live and like
ants on like the Palladium hers in
certain it was nuts played him it was a
right near my brain is [ __ ] dead it's
on santa monica and like wherever motley
crue used to do shows that it was in
that place we went watching live I've
never seen one and I want it's not Dan
Pasternak but it's someone like that huh
and
uh I remember we were pitching a show
called white gorilla to him an animated
series about this silverback gorilla who
moves to LA to become an actor and he
lives with a guy and it's just and this
and the white gorilla does is completely
oblivious to anything like any anything
that like that microaggressions he he
still doesn't understand racism so he
was he had to learn everything so
everything like the fact that he could
walk and talks five but he would
literally like he meets his first black
person like so we ended up doing shorts
for on it for Comedy Central but we
pitched it to him he was like yeah
that's not weird enough for us I don't
wait on a gorilla that lives and he goes
can the gorillas live in a mustache huh
and he was like well it's interesting
because mr. pickle's there's there's a
lot of weird stuff on the show and I
feel like me coming in what I have
really brought and tried to keep is a
more grounded sense of reality so that
the weirdness all kind of somehow makes
sense yeah and i think that is that
dynamic between what what the creators
came up with this weird this dog who has
a layer underground and has a pet [ __ ]
that is dressed up in a levitt you know
[ __ ] suit and barks like a dog and
crawls around on all fours and this dog
loves pickles for some reason and gets a
pickle whenever he's a good boy and yet
somehow it all sort of a little bit
makes sense you know it's did they bring
you in did they bring you in and be like
can you help us figure this out well
what happened was they made an 11-minute
pilot for adult swim and it did very
well an adult swim was like let's try a
22-minute pilot so these guys had never
written anything like that before yeah
so they brought me in and a bunch other
people into sort of after they had
written there there 22-minute pilot to
say like what's working what's not
working whatever and ultimately just
didn't it didn't pan out and Adult Swim
was like let's stick with the 11 minutes
but they asked me to come in and
run the show so that's great yeah it's
been really fun it's been it's literally
like one of the best things that's ever
happened to me but what that's meant is
when I'm working on that show it totally
takes away from it takes up all your
time not just stand up but improv like I
usually do ask at every saturday and
sunday night at UCB and i can't even do
that because i'm working you could think
about it i'll swim is they pay less but
you work more so i'm working like 12 to
16 hours a day seven days a week for the
time that were there were writing that
it's it's like that it's like the louis
ck project like you have to do what you
want but yeah sacrifices you make
sacrifices supra it's your but i have
been talking about going on the road for
a while like I have my own we have a
podcast with a couple of people and I've
put it out there on the podcast and
people have been very generous because I
could never I'm not at the point where I
could go like I want to do all these
improv zand all these funny funny bones
and all these you know because nobody
knows who the [ __ ] I am but to do like a
DIY tour is sort of i think well within
my reach and i would not have a problem
doing that like it wouldn't be a money
making thing it would just be i would
like to get out there and really hone my
next batch of material which i think you
can only really do by going on the road
for a while I think you have to I think
my feelings are for me it's interesting
because you know there was always the
there was always the group of comics
that were like well yeah you could I'm
gonna say this incorrectly by the way so
if I start saying it incorrectly stop me
but meaning like if I'm literalist using
the actual wrong words okay but there
were guys who thought well yeah stop
this is like the UCB comics the guys
that did stand-up at UCB couldn't go out
and do the road because they're
insulated right and then a different
audience its and that which is part
partly true Lucy k said it once why
would I do stand-up at UCB when I could
go to do the road I need strangers to
laugh yeah but here's the opposite of
that and this is what I'll say is that
getting strangers to laugh forms a lot
of very bad habits yes that's the UCB
shakes out of you yet instantly
absolutely so it's like finding the
balance of those two things
the balance and I and I believe and I
wish that I was I wish I number one I
wish I was in LA more number two I wish
I looked more um I wish I I wish I had
maybe at a younger age spent more time
there and so that I felt comfortable
there to go to stand up there that's
also it but I you know honestly that's
not out of the realm of possibility we
kind of the real impossible easily get
over there but but but you're totally
right about the insulation like I Patton
said that to me once uh back in the
green room like I was like hey you know
same thing I was like what advice do you
have for whatever and he's like he's
like do these shows they're great you
have fun audience loves you whatever but
then go to the improv go to laugh
actually go to the store because those
are the places that will make your
comedy bullet proof because nobody knows
you nobody cares nobody gives a [ __ ] who
you are in those places yes and you have
to be [ __ ] funny when you go there
well you were like people go old UCB
darling you earn that right you don't
get that just by hanging out in the
green room you earn it by going on stage
and the people that go there the people
that frequent their end up enjoying you
and you end up you're allowed to take
chances the same way I'm allowed to take
chances when I say go to like DC because
that's my market that I've been best at
where you started no no no that's just
just I randomly not randomly there's a
radio show LA in the morning that is the
number one probably the number one radio
show I'm gonna say in like in a in a
bottom markets there's nothing like that
anymore there's where you go in you do
his show and you sell out all your shows
because everyone [ __ ] listens to
Elliott right there's Tampa Philly um DC
where that where that still exists
there's two guys in the Midwest isn't
there all the top Bob and Tom bob and
tom uh Bob and Tom still like that I
think it used to be not like I mean you
did Bob and Tom like Tosh would fly out
of his way to go do Baba down anytime
that's my Quigley it was was big with
over basically yeah he didn't my private
diver Diaries or something yeah and he
would redo diary readings I mean
Birbiglia was for big news i don't think
gets the respect from comics mmm me i'm
sure he does and i'm sure he doesn't
give a [ __ ] but like he really
[ __ ] came up with some very
innovative ways to run his career oh
he's a genius I will be gene he's a
super funny comic but he's also
brilliant at how to build a career can I
tell you if my / Bigley if you're
listening to this can you come over to
my house and just help me with some
pointers just help me [ __ ] guide it
like if you were me what would you do
because like I got some really great
stories ha like I know Ira Glass how
come I'm not [ __ ] making movies like
but like but it's because his work ethic
and the way he looks at [ __ ] the
doing things yeah he's just he really is
like he's not he's amazing and it has
any fearless on stage in that if he's
got a new story he'll tell it and if it
doesn't work okay i'ma tell another wall
and what was really interesting again
when I was on the road with him was that
he would start on Wednesday with like
just some random observations related to
stuff that he had just experienced and
then to stuff that was in his life and
by Sunday night he would have a tight
new 15 minutes of material that just
came out of being in the moment on stage
on Wednesday night you know amazing I
said I see to pay people people all the
time anytime anyone brings up anything
sleepwalking I'm like well hold of you
but murder my quickly a story like
there's no way to talk about
sleepwalking and not go and not
literally say have you seen his movie
have you read his books have you know
like is he is one man play with [ __ ]
Broadway did you see him on the view
like he's he's very inspirational I'm
one time I saw him it was in Tampa and I
was happen to be a Tampa shooting
something and i walked in i said i want
to meet him like I didn't I never met
him I mean I met him in New York like in
passing by didn't like I never really
you know what I think I was [ __ ]
there when that happened I think you
were I think I was with because I
definitely was in Tampa with him at the
ampa improv what I think I've yes oh
yeah I remember that and I [ __ ]
rolled up and I was like he was just so
he was so that I was the way I wish I
could be like there's so many things i'm
i'm not saying I'm a phony about things
but like like if you walk in my house if
you walk into my green room and you're a
comic I'm like hey man what's up how you
doing all I get out of my chair and be
like right then I'll put on
of an act to make you feel comfortable
right when really quite honestly I'd
rather just sit there and not and be
comfortable enough with who I am he just
goes very zen yeah i walked in i was
like hey man I'm pert he was like hi and
I was like I was like I'm a cop and by
the way I hadn't planned my sentences
out yeah like I'm a comic and he was
like cool do you wanna do a guess that I
was like no no I'm a comic like I just
wanted to say hi like I'm in town and as
I put the [ __ ] am I saying what am I I
shoulda said he said what I wanted to
say yeah and he was just very like
confused he's like oh and then and it
turned out my poster was not remember
that day yes yes and I was like I was
like that's actually me yeah he's like
oh good for you man he knows like looks
like a [ __ ] none of this worked
out the way I thought it would that's
why I just walked out I was like I was I
watched his set and then we had to shoot
the next day so I left but uh huh but
yeah he's an inspir a lot of guys I know
that have worked with them always come
back like I got some good cigars down
there in Tampa I had some really good
two hours yeah I wrote my own or smoked
one of my own and I guy was like what do
you want from it and I was like I want
to feel it I want to feel it buzz mm-hmm
he's like okay and he rolled me the
[ __ ] stiffest the strongest cigar and
we smoked it while rolling another one
and like any so we just SAT there like
old Cubans just it's just it's a
microaggression the UH what are you
anyway what are you I did a grassroots
tour be great who would you go with
would you want to do I don't know that's
what I have to figure out and that's
tricky for me because I'm like there are
so many people you know it's hard I'm in
this weird position where people that
came up with who are doing well are
doing too well to ask him to do
something like that and then the people
who I didn't come up with who are still
coming up and I'm like I don't know who
of those people yeah hey I would trust
to come with be I like their comedy
enough and see i would want to spend
that much time with i mean but i think
it's always like that it's like it's
always like that like I go uh I'm saying
to someone I was like I want to do it
dwarf US tour and they were like that
sounds [ __ ] great mm-hmm and I was
like yeah and then you say the names you
want to do it with I think was like me
Tom Segura our sphere Neal Brown
and they're like a bit none of us are
really like selling like we're all
selling kind of the same group of people
right maybe it's all a little different
but like none of us are selling theaters
enough to warrant like as much money
this a tour bus yeah and then and then
someone's like well if we get you know
Rogen or bill burr on there I go get
them we're just taking their we're just
taking money from them because they
could do it on there and they don't need
that and they don't need that you're
like yeah what the [ __ ] we try it like
it's really difficult to do we get a
group of people because you do have the
people like you know that are you came
up with that are above you and you're
like well those are my peers right they
just happen to be selling theaters on
their own right it's it's really it it's
been problematic I tried to do it I do
this call in sick to work show where I
go in I do radio from like seven to ten
I drink on radio and then I go right to
the club and do a show at eleven oh my
god and I tell on the radio I'm like
everyone call in sick to work Homer
right to the club and so people at
little arias literally turn their car
around go drive straight to the club
daydreams a wide open at seven in the
morning or drinking waiting for me to
show up and then I show up we do it it's
that's brilliant it's not it's
problematic it's unhealthy it's there's
a lot of people who when they decide to
quit does not go to work and start
drinking that is part of their
personality right right like [ __ ] a
[ __ ] show sometimes yeah where's like
just people hammer and then sometimes
it's amazing uh-huh sometimes you get
people waiting in line and they're
[ __ ] pumped up and and I was like I
want to do a call in sick to work tour I
want to do like 13 dates start in tampa
orlando Fort Lauderdale Atlanta like go
all the way work all the way up to DC
and then nmdc and I was like I want to
tour bus I like I'm just drunk in my
room I like in the man cave like typing
it out I want a tour bus I'm gonna yeah
you know what this is how this is how
it's done the idea you got below you got
your little umbrella drink next to you
while you're writing all this yeah I use
don't even [ __ ] start I used to I
this what a phony I am I used to throw
in a Hawaiian shirt when I'd right so I
wanted be like unrest on [ __ ] phony I
am and so I literally
this is what it is tor idea concept
above the talent concept first talent
second don't go and say talents gonna
sell the tour the concept don't sell the
tour people here the idea and go well
that sounds fun and so I star mate right
now the plan I got it it's Delia Tom
Segura get christina pazsitzky get Neal
Brennan get al matter I started like lat
all right and these guys don't have to
do the whole tour they hop on and off
they find when they can't it can't do it
and the beauty is we don't do weekends
cuz there's we only do monday through
friday no work on the weekend yeah and
i'm like this is [ __ ] great and i
like call my manager and she's like okay
you don't meet your bus costs she's like
this is a horrible idea she's like you
honestly you could save money by uber
agree [ __ ] serious like I'm not even
joking it would be less expensive for
you to uber your way to DC than to get a
[ __ ] tour bus so I was like whoa well
there's an option yeah so uh the Oprah
tour but yeah the uber tour but that's
fun maybe that's not a bad idea but it's
the it's you're right about that is that
it is hard to find talent to do it i
have i have a map at home you know when
I put this out of the podcast people
have emailed me and said I'd be
interested in helping you whatever you
know I'd love for you to come to where I
am it's not you know club owners or
theater owners or anything like that
it's just like a group of guys in
bellevue washington or what is a great
place to do stand-up yeah well these
guys I got some fans up there so and
they're dying for me to come up there
but you know it's like figuring out like
you said it's figuring out what's the
hook what's the thing that's going to
sell people on coming to the show
because what I wouldn't want to do and
it could easily turn into this but I
wouldn't want to do is go I'll come up
there and then go to and and I'm just in
a bar with a group of people playing
pool next to where I'm you know forming
and it's just like a basically a an open
mic except I'm there you know what I
mean yeah but there is that you know
there's a lot to be said about the idea
of doing these graphs cruise tours you
get a lot more money than doing the
club's mm-hmm like I mean one nighters
in general are not a bad shake yeah like
they really turn out and especially
through podcasting podcast seems really
changed not only
dialogue between comics and fans like
comics and audiences but like the
concept of touring I mean and I keep
saying Tom Segura but like it's only
because I'm really good friends with him
he his stand-up like I don't I don't
even know if he does clubs anymore oh
really like he just is doing one
nighters and he's doing him at rock
venues where people will come and see
him because they've heard his podcast
people come and see him and it's him and
his wife they'll do like a live podcast
at a at a venue in Dallas one night and
then do stand-up the next night and it's
the same people coming out for two
different things it's like it really is
i'm at look at dubbed i came up with it
i'm not i mean i have to pay tribute to
[ __ ] Benson cuz i came up with a call
in sick to work show because he has a
420 show and I thought how [ __ ]
genius you're getting the club when they
don't have business normal he's doing it
at 420 in the afternoon he doesn't a 420
on Sundays nice so like he'll do a 420
sure not every sunny but like what c'mon
I'll be on the road he'll be like this
is way he just lives his life here in DC
i'll be in DC i'm gonna do a 420 show
when you're there and then I was seeing
I was in San Francisco he did a 420 show
and a midnight show on 419 to celebrate
420 he sold out both of them I didn't
sell a [ __ ] ticket like he sold out
to shows bookending my show at odd hours
I never was supposed to come to the
[ __ ] club everyone's like oh there
was a show at seven thirty I didn't know
about that one when did you guys start
to him at seven thirty what the hell's
going on yeah I think Benton's and a
really inspirational guy but he's a guy
who and then this is this has always
been my problem also and I think you've
done this too it's like you have who you
are as a cut like what you're going for
as a comic you know yeah like your thing
is you're the call in sick to work guy
or what I really your thing but like I'm
a fama party guy I'm a fun party I when
you come to my show you should walk out
smiling a fun guy who's having fun at a
party right yeah and and doug is the guy
who gets high and you know and i'm like
i dont i I've never been able to really
you know it's like I'm the guy who reads
too much you know or what it's like 10
there's a very accurate statement but it
is a market of people
like the people that are say this guy's
name a linked site no I like him and he
knows i like him I mean it sounds gonna
sound like I like couldn't ah Barry show
or do not go to my show right right now
Todd berries like uh that's not an
insult it's a compliment it's not an
insult it's compliment like i did a
weekend right after like I came in and
did a one nighter in in Tennessee in
Nashville after Michael Ian Black very
different audiences yeah like maybe the
club said we don't think any of those
people have ever been to our club right
and I went oh yeah like it's like Jimmy
Kimmel showed up in mid late night and
had a brand new group of people that
weren't watching late night right like
and so it's uh I fine i think you're
right is you gotta find then you got to
be like the guy who does this like I
like people who do this so I want to go
see a guy who does this and talks about
doing this and my you know I always I
was the worst show I ever had the worst
show I ever had was a midnight show at
stand-up New York and it was myself
three comics yeah myself Lisa Lampanelli
it was Jim Norton okay and I went last
oh why was this when Lisa Lampanelli was
wearing the gold rings and the medallion
I don't even remember there was a point
that Lisa Lampanelli was laughable to
watch on stage oh really she's oh very
funny but she was she would go up with a
with a Mercedes emblem like a big one
and then her fingers covered in rings
and she would be like the hip hop like
yo brothers but it was just like you
know so Lisa Lampanelli goes up and
talks about how much she loves big black
[ __ ] yeah Jim Norton goes up and talks
about how he loves murdering hookers and
storing their heads in his closet and
then I go up and I'm like guys what's up
with time travel no and the audience was
just like I'm absurd if I'm you travel
I'm obsessed with [ __ ] time travel I
had to but I told this on stage but I'll
tell you I'll a my youngest is a little
she little out there she's an
interesting kid uh-uh she's dyslexic but
she she's got a very weird brain how old
nine very interesting brain like so
she's a real person at this point she's
a real person that's just like a little
little she's a real person yeah so my
wife my wife and her friends go to
Europe and I'm staying with the kids and
I'm on there a lot so like doing TV
we're doing I'm on the road a lot and so
I'm staying with the kids for the first
time like I'm really staying with him
and I'm connecting with them like I
don't do that often that sounds really
horrible but yeah it's [ __ ] part of
the gig so seem like a bad guy and so
Isla yells in four bedroom dad I need to
talk to you so I come into her bedroom
and she's in a bunk bed so I'm like I
level with her by standing it's she's
laying in her bed with her back and she
just flips up on her side like this she
goes do you believe in time travel by
the way I'm obsessive time travel so
literally I am pot committed right away
I'm like I [ __ ] do I got do and she
was like do you think it's possible that
I came from the future told myself a
secret I was like yes and the she's
frozen backs against all I want to know
ah and I was like baby what's a secret
but like I love time travel I love touch
my wife believes there's two times
people people who like time traveling
movies and people who don't like time
traveling movies and I am in the first
group yeah well if it's done well it's
great with name a bad time travel movie
um time cop which ones that jean-claude
van Damme okay okay nailed it this time
well I'll tell you who doesn't like time
travel is people who like watching Lisa
Lampanelli do big black [ __ ] jokes and
Jim Norton doing murdering hookers jokes
I mean it was literally like you know
you remember those shows that midnight
at santam New York it's an hour so you
do 20 minutes yes I'm up there for 20
minutes they those guys both they're
both great comics they both [ __ ] kill
the whole time they're up there I go up
there it is packed room so 200 people
and stand up New York it is silent the
entire time I'm up there just silent
nobody Hackl nothing I finally get to
the end of my set I'm doing my last joke
I go well I'm gonna do one more thing
and get out of here and just from the
way back of the room very low but
audible enough that everybody in the
room can hear it you just hear a guy go
thank God
oh I disco I'm with you sir I'm with you
I wish that more people respected like I
wish there was a group of people that
liked a good comics who thought like you
know what I mean I huh like comics that
in and of that moment is what is
brilliant and beautiful and not say that
there's nothing wrong with like I don't
mind the guy who's got to prepare to act
who does one hour of the same exact
stuff but a guy who could who like like
when you like you saying that in the
moment it's one of the funniest things
gonna hear all [ __ ] night I'm with
you sir just silent like I'm just up
there and and you know what I luckily
was late enough you know I've been doing
it long enough yeah that I did not come
off stage and feel particularly badly
yeah yeah like early on in my career I
would have been like I suck i'm horrible
whatever but I came up stage and I
literally I was just like well I held my
20 minutes i did my 20 minutes I didn't
complain I didn't get mad at them I
didn't blame them I just did my jokes
and they were not interested you know
and that's that's fine um it's it I Dyke
I came off this stage like maybe maybe a
month ago now but uh and i had a
mediocre set at best like at the store a
mediocre set and that best and rogan and
Bill berwyn had gone up before and after
me and just destroyed both them
destroyed book handed me bill destroyed
Joe destroyed and I was really down I
was like I was like [ __ ] man like god
damn it wide oh I had the same audience
and then I'm laying in bed I'm like
other the two best comics working right
maybe maybe that's it maybe just happen
to be friends with the greatest ones
doing it it don't just cuz you're
friends with them doesn't mean that this
is you should be as funny as that those
guys are pretty good yeah [ __ ] it bill
burr month like monster destroyed and
Rogan had this bit that I stink of I
can't think of him without thinking
about a great this [ __ ] bit is about
Caitlyn Jenner I was like it's one of
the best that's one of the [ __ ]
greatest perspectives on that careful be
careful yeah I mean that goes back to
what we were talking about before yeah
you know that
ol that whole controversy with the stuff
bill burr dead on Conan about Caitlyn
Jenner know what happened uh you know he
he did some jokes that I thought were
really funny about how he has to get
used to it because he came up when this
guy was the greatest athlete in the
world and now he's a woman or she's a
what like he was just kind of like
getting into how confusing it can be and
stuff and just got so much Twitter
outrage are you serious yeah um I wonder
if it's a wonder i wonder if like if you
could bottling of the American mind
coddling of the American mind I wonder
how much there is it there is a weird
thing about about life that like I stop
saying to my kids the other night I was
like you know understand like when I
grew up like it there is that thing
where I go think like I was in a
generation where I've witnessed I
witnessed change more than any
generation probably previous other than
maybe the like the Rockefeller
generation went when industry came in
and cities started changing and cars
showed up like this my lifetime our
lifetime has had more change than
anything we when I was a kid growing up
in Florida I don't know who I was saying
this to but like the N word was used a
lot like oh really Oh a lot like not by
myself or my parents but like growing up
in the South you would hear it anyway
and you'd hear it unapologetically right
at ass grocery store and buy a white
person and you know just keep your head
down right and I mean in our
neighborhood there it was it was a it
was part of an adjective like you
through that word at the beginning of
the end of another like phrase burb yeah
a verb and that became the way that verb
was displayed right like I'm not getting
too into exile like talking about that
but no yeah I've no idea we're talking
about but so yeah but like and then we
went through emails to the internet
through the accessibility of the world
through political correctness I mean
political correctness has changed
everything in so much well I almost feel
like the political correctness thing is
almost a reversion
to making things more difficult to talk
about oh yeah that's what that whole
cuddling of the American minds about is
that good political aggression or
political correctness and trigger words
translate is right that they're not
teaching they want they're not teaching
the legalities of sexual assault in
legal classes in college anymore because
kids complained and it seems like the
person that gets most offended in the
classroom is the one who's got the
loudest voice so now there's a teacher
said I was obsessive set and I quit
teaching and is what I was listening on
unto an NPR because he said I I was
asked to snot no longer teach the rape
laws and sexual assault laws in class
trigger because it was a trigger for
people and he said the person that hurts
the most is the victim in the like
because now I'm not teaching something
so what who will get hurt the most is
the person who will possibly one day get
raped because now bunch of these kids
don't know the legalities of this right
because I can't teach it in a school
where it's supposed to be a breeding
ground for thought and for constructive
thought and a gret in a place where
you're supposed to come up with great
ideas that's what college was like for
me I remember it showing up and I was
mostly with drugs but like but like I
showed up and I remember like feeling
like I'd learned about like the Grateful
Dead and like fish and widespread panic
and like and like all these things about
like things I didn't know about yeah I
was not I was not good in college so did
you did you I was I was really young
when I went to college I just turned 17
really and I really felt it like I felt
much younger than everybody there I'd
gone to an all-boys high school so this
is my first time like dealing with girls
and stuff yeah I mean I you know had a
girlfriend in high school and everything
but like dealing with that on a regular
basis and I felt felt weirdly
unsocialized compared to everybody else
which was totally not true but was a
huge barrier in my head and that's sort
of i don't know i think part of my
comedy comes from that of like always
feeling outside of everything else and
not part of everything
but so when I got to college I was like
okay I'm younger than everybody
everybody else is cooler than me so I'm
gonna try to be cooler than them or show
them as how cool I am by staying up
later drinking more you know doing less
work going to class less often than
everybody else it was really kind of a
waste of four years you know or I was in
seven well I found out second semester
senior year I fell the class and wasn't
able to graduate on time which was very
traumatic because I did go home and tell
my parents to cancel their hotel
reservations and tell all my family they
weren't going to come up with my
graduation so that was a and by the way
at most schools if you fail a class
second semester senior year you can
still go through graduation because i
know you'll you'll get your degree but
the habit of me not at my school filled
two classes my senior year and they
still let me walk yeah and then they
told me yeah you need to take
correspondence classes teacher wouldn't
pass me most most places are like that
and so I moved to New York take took
correspondence classes hung out at that
astor place barnes and noble do remember
that place yeah yeah i used to work
there oh really ended up working there
but i'd hang out there and i get coffee
and i'd work and try to [ __ ] get
through these classes in for many years
that was where i went to get my hair cut
all the time oh oh right right oh really
right there yeah I never got a haircut
there was great there was a ten bucks I
love that whole little area dining these
haircuts bro get him high and tight you
know yeah lots on the top and nothing on
the sides when did you move to LA 2004
really what was it what was the point um
I always had this idea in my head that I
was going to move to LA when somebody
asked me to like when somebody gave me a
job yeah and that just wasn't happening
and I actually came out here in 2003 to
work on a show for better that Besser
did called cross-balls for Comedy
Central Ross balls was a really funny
show so I came out here for like three
weeks and I had an agent by then out
here and I was that was cross-balls was
when a make-believe person or argue a
real person correct it was a great show
so I got to be on it a couple times and
then did some right
yeah oh I'm gonna go watch some cross
balls hi I bet they're ten times funnier
now that I'm a smarter [ __ ] comic I
had some fun on that show but when I
came out here my agent was like I'll set
up some meetings for you so I was here
for three weeks and in one week I think
I had like 15 meetings around town with
every network in production company and
management agency and whatever and I was
like this is elias great i'm gonna come
out here i'm gonna move out here it's
gonna be you know so i moved out here in
2004 and [ __ ] nothing you know
nothing um it's amazing how quickly they
forget and go on with their own lives
yeah well if you're from somewhere else
then you're interesting but if you're
from here nobody cares yeah you know
you're just another yahoo in LA but I
was lucky actually because I did get my
first real sitcom writing job within
eight months of moving out here and what
shows that it was a show called love inc
which was on UPN it was about a dating
service where they would go out with you
and be your wingman it started busy
philipps and Holly Robinson Peete and i
will say it was not a it was not a great
show but it was a great experience for
me because it really taught me how to
write sitcoms you know yeah we did we
did a full season so I did 22 episodes
of that show and so you learned the
straw ash and education yeah looks like
a master's class yeah yeah and the cool
thing about that show was one day we
were in the writers room and they both
walked in naked no no the assistant is
somebody's assistant comes in and goes
um quentin tarantino's assistant is on
the phone and he wants to know the
system wants to know if Quentin can have
dvds of every episode of the show
because he loves the show and a friend
of mine Andy secunda who created the
show was like this has to be somebody
playing a prank or whatever like this is
a joke but sure send them you know
wherever they want to send him you know
and so we had this whole debate like was
it real was it not real was it real and
then apparently at the Oscars that year
it was it was the year that Michelle
Williams maybe was nominated some
his friends with busy philipps a busy
went to the Oscars and she went to a
party Quentin Tarantino was all the way
across the room and as soon as she
walked in he was like busy and Mike came
running over was talking about I really
love the show and yeah so you know
obviously Quentin Tarantino has some
weird tastes but that's edition guy I
saw him I saw him in new york at the
starbucks that's off of seventh avenue
in between bleecker and West Third there
you should be a starbucks on between
bleecker and West third uh-huh Bleeker
almost fourth okay and there was a
starbucks like right around there I saw
him writing uh I I can only assume Jo it
was no it was no this was so long ago
this is like true romance no no no no
not that long but he was writing all of
whatever it knows I only assume it was
kill bill kill Bo and he was writing it
in a in on a he writes long and yeah
longhand and I went I was well just read
an interview with him yesterday and he
says and I love it because I write
longhand to I can't do it on the
computer really and he was like the guy
goes do you still write everything out
longhand and he's like if you were
writing a poem would you do it on the
computer which i thought was such a very
[ __ ] I wrote my book on computer and
I was like wells goods I won't lose it
uh but uh but I that I've tried road I
tried writing a script in uh I've been
having these great moments that I go oh
that's a sick a moment like but it's not
on sitcoms right now uh-huh like that
doesn't exist but it was a great sitcom
moment like I go oh that's a good scene
right what's happening right now I was
very funny it's a good scene like
yesterday we drop off we drop off one of
the Goodman kids and my wife walks her
into the house and I'm alone with me and
my two daughters and I said that my
wife's walking and i go i love your
mom's waddle and that my daughter's go
there you're very lucky she married you
and I said so well you should have seen
the chick out almost married and they're
like what and I go yeah I start making
up this person or name is Penelope and
they're like what did she look like can
I go she was like 5 10 blonde hair and I
could she was a champion diver and
start making up this person it was
really fun I go yeah we she was a kid
she got him a break bank robbery and she
had had their parents had to move her to
the mountains and I start really like a
lab rat and I was I mean fun creating
this character my daughters are
listening and then realized how much
they're gonna have to pay in therapy
after the fact that you just lied to
them like that and so my wife gets in
the car and they go mom did dad really
have a girly almost married and by the
way that not there wasn't a girl I
almost marry but there was a girl before
my wife yeah it was like there was a
crossroad probably more than one girl
there was one girl that was crossover
and I'm still friends with so my wife
thought I was talking about her my
wife's like oh I was like oh I don't
mean and they're like we she did she
really have a wolf and my wife's like a
wolf said yeah she was the president of
the rescue for cats and dogs I'm just
painting pictures of [ __ ] all my
daughters like and I was like wait what
was her name and Georgia goes Penelope
and my wife goes yeah Penelope figment
that was a last name and then they're
like wait who you gonna marry and I
start drawing this picture of my wife's
guy go his name was quirky and I start
painting this character of this guy it
was so funny and I was like oh that
could be like if i sat down and tried to
write that I bet I could make that
funnier yeah that's a good moment and
then in a family type sitcom yeah but
like I'm a different kind of dad so it's
like me like you know I but I so I was
like I'll be you know then I don't know
so then but it's why I've been writing
in my joke book up my joke book to a
bigger book and I've been riding in the
back just scenes and I think are funny
and then writing outside to have that
stuff because then when it comes time to
actually write something you can just go
look at all that and go please what
about this what about this and then when
I put them on my computer they just
disappear cuz you don't know where they
are but it's not in something I don't
flip through it I don't yeah it's not a
place of things to play there's a
problem I mean for me to like I don't
i'm not good at organizing stuff
anywhere but especially on the computer
yeah how many shows have you written on
um I couldn't tell you but I would say
somewhere in the vicinity of seven or
eight maybe yeah do you ever try to
write your own show for yourself no I
never had I'm trying to write I I've
literally never even written a pilot for
anything like i've never even written a
spec pilot really which is bad
cuz I should have that at this point so
I'm trying to write one right now and
the main character is definitely I would
not play him but it's definitely based
on me yeah it's funny I had a meeting
with my agents to talk about this idea
and I mentioned it came out of like me
just falling into an internet hole and
finding out stuff and you know whatever
and I'm like I go you know because I was
47 and I was like you know when if you
have a good relationship with at least
one sibling when you're 47 that is a
predictor of a longer and happier life
than other people so I want to write
this so I'm saying to them I want to
write this show about this guy who
figures out all these little things yes
to do to make himself live you know and
who I like that they go I didn't I first
thing that I goes as he goes okay but
could he be younger than that could he
be a younger guy I [ __ ] like that oh
that's like it's like almost when you go
like when you look online and the and
they say things that they're like people
who walk 10,000 steps we're not to leave
the hell like I look that [ __ ] it's
almost like a like a like life hacks
right like you find things out you like
notice them mm-hmm I really like that so
anyway you know his immediate reaction
was like that's way too [ __ ] old you
know yeah and I was like I am NOT that's
not the point the point is just like you
know you're missing the [ __ ] you're
looking damn bark on a tree going I
don't feel or is it [ __ ] i hate when
they agents do that they just like oh
they're coming to see me do stand-up
tonight so I'm a little bit instead of
tonight I'm doing well I can't say
because I'm taping something and we're
not allowed to say what's the world oh
yeah but this isn't gonna air today so
no this is coming out none oh yeah
anywhere I'll ask you all fair um but
anyway it's like I've just started
working with these guys because I didn't
even have an agent when I got this mr.
pickles thing and I was like I'm the
[ __ ] head writer of a show I should
have an agent by now yeah so I started
working with these guys and they're
great I like them a lot but we're still
it's like we're in the early dating
phases the thing about the thing I think
about age
is um you don't want to be your friends
mm-hmm that's the biggest mistake I've
made it's having an agent be your friend
it then it's like all of a sudden it's
like now I'm not talking about by the
way I'm not talking about like a booking
agent like there's booking agents that
have been my friend I worked with matt
frost for a long time and I love him
dearly i still do but like as far as
your agent agents you want them to kind
of respect you and but not like be like
your boy right I I fell into that a
couple times where they're like at an
agent who just wanted a party and you'd
go out to parties and and you need to
fight it up how parties and you'd go out
and do fun stuff you'd introduce them to
hot chicks and then you're like am I
you're like your [ __ ] agent like I'm
gonna rely on these guys to introduce me
two hot chicks yeah like you i like i
like the ones I'm with now over at UTA
and I like it because I walked in and
they looked at me as a guy who could
make that money yeah and I was like
that's what I want to look at me like
yeah you want them to have dollar signs
in their eyes yeah and they're like that
yeah exactly and that's [ __ ] up but
that is the system I want them to I used
to say I people who say their guy like
Mitch Hedberg oh they kept him on the
road too long I want that i want the guy
that's like I don't give a [ __ ] about
his elf right he needs to figure that
[ __ ] out but I want to make money off
this guy right cuz in that way I'll make
money like I don't like I mean but my
managers are different they're like well
Burt you need to check all December off
and I'm like not gonna your liver needs
to take all of December off do you drink
yeah do you uh her a lot a lot yeah me
too [ __ ] love it the bastard Frank no
no he smokes pot right yeah but what is
that did you ever smoke pot and do
improv no I'm not I've never been a pot
smoker i mean i wish i had been a pot
smoker because i feel like i do well
sometimes I enjoy it sometimes I don't I
also feel like it's so much less harmful
to you then drinking is but I just never
got into it how come how come to UCB
doesn't have a show on Comedy Central
just a UCB show' they used to write did
they had they show the best talent in
the club's coming out of doing so many
other things at this point I mean you
know Ian Roberts is one of the show
runners at Key & Peele which is now
ending but he's running another show on
TV land and Amy obviously has done
really well for herself but Matt Walsh
is on veep and he's on I did by the way
I didn't know I didn't know Matt Walsh
was Matt Walsh oh really I didn't know I
knew him as the guy on dog bites man
which I also wrote for I was a great
show yeah it was a really great show I
knew him as a guy on dog bites man and
then ran into him in an audition not
knowing he's that Matt Walsh uh-huh and
I said him and I love dog bites man and
he's such a nice sweet guy he just said
oh thank you very much we ended up
talking at this audition and then I said
man the guy from in my head I'm like the
guy from dog bites man is a [ __ ]
really nice guy then I a [ __ ] drive
I'm in this neighborhood he lives in
this neighborhood and with every so
funny because I've been to his house and
I haven't been there like in a year or
two but I was like this is right
werewolf's lives when I was driving over
here and I said um I said we do every
fourth of July there's a big parade for
the families everyone gets on the bikes
and we all dress our bikes up and run
her by Trump and I saw Matt Walsh and I
went I know that guy how do I know that
guy and in my head I couldn't figure of
it was man versus man bites dog or dog
bites man or or what and I went that's
interesting and I was trying to take a
picture of my daughter I sometimes I'll
take my camera hang it low and instead I
ended up getting a picture of his calf
hit and it looked amazing it was talking
about the child of his cow right yeah
right right right but he was on a
child's bike riding a child's bike and
it happened that his calf look yoked and
I went I know that guy I know that guy I
got a picture of his calf I ever run
into him again I'm gonna tell him I got
the best [ __ ] it's a good picture of
him by the way cuz it's a picture you
know after your calf but you see him
once if I find this I'm gonna [ __ ]
post it but um and then I saw him over
at Maria I see them coffee shop that
over there that everyone everyone the
neighborhood ends up going to uh huh and
I saw him I go dude I walk up to him I'm
like I got the most amazing picture of
your calf and he's not the kind of guy
that's like oh cool said uh excuse me
yeah but yeah Matt Walsh is very
talented he's a great actor great actor
but all that but all the the school and
all the people going through UCB like
there should be oh there's I mean broad
city as people who came out of UCB yeah
and then you know every time I turn on
the TV every show has people from UCB on
it uh so they're you know they're a
factory at this point yeah yeah what's
your podcast my podcast is called the
long shot I was I thought that's what it
was and it's it's at the longshot
podcast com it's um just myself and a
woman who's a comic named amber Kenny
and a guy who says he's a comic I don't
know that he is whose name is Jamie flam
he's also the Booker at the improv and
he's a he's a baffled man um but I love
him well Jamie is it just the three of
you it's the three of us we have guests
a lot of him oh I'm sorry we have a new
guest we have a new host this season we
when we started the show Eddie Pepitone
was one of the hosts I heard you in
Eddie Pepitone and I watched I've
watched you and Eddie Pepitone online oh
really yeah and then Eddie left the show
to do his own podcast and we didn't have
it was just three of us and now Joe
Wagner who's a very funny guy has joined
us one of the hosts and we often have
guests on the rugby guess I would love
to have you as a yes i love you on
improv for humans oh thanks so fun I
love improv for human it's so fun with
fashion and I that's it ear wolf you
guys shoot that a deer wolf your wolf
yeah yeah I've been there so many times
I was like oh that's such a great
[ __ ] show it's really fun yeah but we
do the long shot in my kitchen so really
we did it at ATC for a while but it just
didn't have the same vibe it's like in
my you know I love atc and you know
thank God Alan bill put that all
together yeah but the studio and ATC
it's you sit in a semi-circle so no it's
facing each other yeah and in my kitchen
we're all sitting around the table
looking right at each other and it's
just it's a different vibe I'll tell you
I'll tell you the only podcast I've ever
done at ATC that well I take that back
to podcast I've done at ATC that um that
the studio was in a hindrance I meaning
meaning uh the setup the setup was a
punch-drunk sports and Philippe Esparza
Felipe Esparza do you know Philippe no
okay you see the guy who was on last
comic standing he is the
long hair fascinating guy uh-huh you
gotta get on your podcast yeah you
really is interesting and [ __ ] really
[ __ ] fascinating uh-huh that's what
the one thing that's so cool about being
in this network is that you come home
and you're like hey man like I just saw
all of you got so many of you guys that
I wanted to talk to I feel I feel
uncomfortable honestly I feel
comfortable reaching out to oh really
acts like I'm like I don't like uh like
I'm afraid people are gonna be like I
don't know who the [ __ ] you are oh no
that's not true it's funny because it's
funny you say that because when when I
got that email that said bert wants to
have people on his podcast you know yeah
never I was like I'll email him I don't
know if he'd want me on the show but
yeah are you [ __ ] kidding me but so
[ __ ] me yes just everybody's image of
themselves is so different from
everybody's image of other people what
I'd like to do what I'd like to do more
of what I'm trying to I got to a place I
had a very big tentpole month in my
podcast where I got more numbers than
I've ever [ __ ] gotten was your
transformers period yes and and what it
was though was it was just the fact that
everyone on that podcast that month was
famous right and I was like and it was
cool it was very cool to talk to them
but I felt like chasing after famous
people was not like that's exactly what
we did with the long shot early on it
was like we no one's gonna listen to us
you get Paul of talk on this person on
VI get better on you get what I noticed
after a while was that for us it didn't
make a huge difference in the numbers
whether we had somebody very well known
somebody not known nobody yeah so it
gets the point where it's like we have
our dedicated audience let's just have
[ __ ] fun doing this and it's not you
don't want to just get the people to
download you on that episode because
they saw the guy they like Mar Maron is
gonna be on there yeah and so what I
like to do and I do this I do this I'm
going to do this more often what I'd
like to do is do this hang out with
people that where you can just hang out
with other comics and just talk we can
talk about whatever right I love that
I've done I did Jackie Kashian yesterday
I did Owen Benjamin yesterday uh you I
got like a bunch of really great [ __ ]
talent
people just to shoot the [ __ ] with but
what I really want to do and then I'm
going to do a solo podcast in the week
the middle of week I'm gonna do one by
myself to work on whatever to talk out
loud about whatever i'm thinking and
then what I'd like to do is I want to
start doing more of where I bring like
four people in we just drink and shut
the door that would be fun and like and
do it to it it like the end of the night
or maybe like I did one with the with a
bunch of black black guys and it was
called my lack cast and we drank like
eight nine in the morning ever [ __ ]
lit by 11 when we wrapped it up and I
was like I got if I could take a nap
like it but those ones where people come
over Drake or the best you gotta be
careful I we've done that a few times on
our show and it's getting really fun
like we'll we'll just pop open a bottle
of Jameson's or something and you know
it's been great then we had one episode
and I will tell you this i have a thing
where once in a while not often but
maybe every three or four months because
this business is so up and down yes so
I'll do something I was working on mr.
pickles I finished mr. pickles and it's
like being on a boat in the doldrums in
the middle of the ocean you got nothing
in front of you nothing behind you you
don't know what the [ __ ] is gonna happen
and so I do a thing where i will just
once in a while go full-on Charles
Bukowski and just leave my house at
eleven o'clock in the morning and go
find a bar and start drinking and it's
fun for me it's like I love it I meet
crazy people but they're all really
interesting and yeah whatever so I did
that then I came home and I realized we
had a podcast recording that night so
it's like I've been drinking all day
it's now four thirty your five o'clock
in the afternoon yeah at six people are
showing up to do the podcast and I'm
like okay let me take a nap for half an
hour but I'm wasted you know so they
show up to do the and I really what I
should have done was was I should have
called in sick I called in sick that day
they show up Jamie brings a bottle of
whiskey with him so now I start drinking
again and I was just having difficulty
stringing senses to get what I was like
is that the number i don't know the
number but it was the last episode of
season nine and I na you know it's like
I couldn't even list
to it because I turned it on and you
know that drunk voice people have some
times where it's like you're trying to
say um as soon as I heard that I was
like oh [ __ ] this and I had that I had a
thing in my head where I was like I
don't want to release this episode but
then I was like you know what I'm a
grown-up let me just accept
responsibility for my actions and of
course our fans are so dedicated that
I'm sure a lot of them hated it but a
lot of them were like that was my
favorite episode it whenever I get drunk
on an episode everyone [ __ ] loves you
like I got every time I've ever done
Rogan there like if I'm not drinking
they're like you're not drinking like
well I thought I'd take the day I'm
trying to be healthy oh [ __ ] healthy man
I gotta [ __ ] drive a forklift but i
will never i will never do that again I
mean I'm not saying I won't have a drink
on the show but I will never just be
well hopefully loaded and then get more
loaded as the show goes on yeah well I'm
gonna try to set them up I'm gonna try
to set him up with the emails i got i'm
gonna like do it through my wife the way
I've been doing it and I'm gonna try to
set up like like I come in town and like
hey guys let's do like let's do like a
like a [ __ ] 5pm early cocktail sunset
great and to get like fourth and if
you're in awe yeah absolutely I'd love
to do it dude thank you so much for
doing this i really thank you for having
me she's been [ __ ] it's been this is
what this is the reason I podcast
honestly because we never get this
opportunity to ya know I was just saying
that somebody my cousin is a is a comedy
nerd and I saw him down in Virginia last
week we were talking he listens to my
podcast but he also listens to
everybody's podcasts and I love it
because you know it means there's one
person in my family who kind of
understands the world I live in and what
I do which nobody understands that you
know yeah and we were talking about it
and I was like when do you ever i love
the podcast that i do and i love doing
this because when do you ever get to sit
down with one person or two people and
just have an uninterruptible I mean
you're at a bar and there's people you
know coming up and we
you just don't do it I don't talk this
way to my family let alone and off i
mean i say this i say this is a fan of
podcasting how awesome is it to listen
to two very funny people talk mm-hmm
like it's one of the what the one if you
can tell me where there's a podcast like
that that would be great
I
you
this episode was brought to you by the
Machine
you